well it feels great to be back
thank you so much for sticking by and
jointly exploring this discursive path
of consciousness theoretical physics and
the philosophy of what fundamental
reality even means here's an outline of
what to expect from the theories of
everything project the toe channel in
the next few months and there are time
stamps included for you to skip around
january that is the next two weeks all
of this will be done in the next two
weeks
we're dedicated thematically to
exploring mathematics limiting theorems
and the understanding of free will
guests include yoshibok john verveicky
david walpart who by the way has three
limiting theorems underneath his belt
which is an unmatched feat stefan
alexander of the autodidactic universe
string theory in the autodidactic
universe which is a machine learning
model of physics whereby the universe
generates its own laws or at least
learns them in a manner akin to a
restricted boltzmann machine at least in
their first draft of the autodidactic
universe we're also going to be talking
to professor norman wildberger on why
infinity isn't real and by extension the
real numbers aren't necessarily real per
se that is they don't correspond to
something physical the reason to explore
limiting theorems and no-go theorems is
because many people are constructing
their own theory of everything their own
toe and they do so
with
an overzealousness with a hubris rather
than a humility as they valiantly claim
some fact that trivially violates some
no-go theorem or known limiting theorem
in math and physics without realizing
that they are it's helpful to know when
one is violating the bounds of what's
considered to be possible or what's not
possible and to subsequently show how
you found a loophole by not using one of
the assumptions that are integral to the
no go theorem essentially knowledge of
limiting theorems are useful to both
those who are trying to understand toes
and those who are trying to construct
their own toll
february is a month where we'll be
exploring more of the topic of ufos and
consciousness starting with salvatore
pis soon i'll make a post soliciting
questions for salvatore as first what i
want to do is go through the navy
patents with a fine-tooth comb go
through his papers
and understand them salvatore has agreed
to do two podcasts the first of which
will be an introduction to his work and
the second will answer any new or
lingering questions that you have after
ruminating over the first as well as in
february george knapp and colm keller
are coming on for a theolocution they're
going to be discussing skinwalkers at
the pentagon as they've at least
privately disclosed to me that people
have barely
scraped the surface of that book during
other interviews and podcasts also in
february frank yang is coming up on
consciousness carl fristen on
consciousness as well and i can announce
here for the first time that
yoshibok and donald hoffman will be
coming on for a theolocution on
consciousness as well that's something
we've been trying to schedule we've been
scheduling back and forth for almost a
year and finally it
looks like it's going to arrive in the
middle of february additionally and this
is also in february herb mertz is going
to be coming on to speak about the
global consciousness project we'll be
exploring the connection between
consciousness and
randomness which is a peculiar
juxtaposition i'm aware however there's
anomalous data with respect to rngs that
is random number generators and
high valence emotional events such as a
measurable deviation in randomness
during globally fractious events like
911. it's a curious fact that these
sensors and i'll be speaking in detail
about what these sensors are that these
sensors go off sometimes minutes prior
to an actual event which indicates that
consciousness either interacts backward
in time or has some predictive powers
still and we're in february i have to
read these now we have a highly
requested guest a h almas regarding
consciousness as well as gary nolan
regarding the physical evidence of ufo
interactions and noam chomsky
is coming on for a one-on-one forget
about live forget about ama it's coming
on for one on one just about the
philosophy of language and meaning i'm
super super excited about that in
particular because i don't know the last
time i was able to speak privately to
chomsky starting march i'm going to be
placing an emphasis on choosing new
professors instead of the
standard podcast trope of interviewing
the same people
over and over which leads to
invariably to this feedback loop where
the already famous are interviewed on
every podcast even right now i'm on the
lookout for new professors with new
lines of research professors who don't
have their own channel nor have been
interviewed by many people to bring
fresh ideas to the fore much like we did
with the michael levin interview which i
highly recommend march will also be the
month of exploring rigorous mathematical
unification attempts such as that of
edward frankl and the langlins program
as well as kevin knuth has a new
unannounced theory that links
mathematics and physics
and norman wildberger has a new model of
mathematics starting march we're also
going to be exploring more quantum
gravity approaches like euclidean
gravity and asymptotically safe gravity
the latter of which is the only known
quantum gravity approach that has some
experimental validation and yet almost
no one in the public sphere talks about
it and it would be great to help change
that there will also be the exploration
of data on near-death experiences with
dean raiden to be honest from my cursory
glance at this data about 15 years ago
and it lasted about 15 minutes i didn't
do much research it seemed like there
was
so much data on it that the reports can
be cherry-picked to indicate that
consciousness survives after physical
death and i've had that inexorable
mindset in me since i was a contamilious
atheist however much of what i thought
to be true turned out to be vastly
incorrect and i'd like to explore the
veracity of these nde claims rather than
rejecting them prior to seriously
looking into them i think it'll be a
great deal of fun now for the middle of
the year i'd like to start putting out
more theo locutions i'd like the
theories of everything project to be a
place where academics can conduct
research and collaborate in front of an
audience for example mike 11 and carl
fristen will be coming on together
later this year with each fomenting
ideas in the other in a speculative
fashion grounded in their research much
like what would happen behind the closed
doors of academia except now it will be
in front of you and by the way i use
that term project the theories of
everything project
judiciously rather than saying podcast
because there's a goal in mind with the
toe channel that is decidedly not well
let's just have a conversation it's best
to think of toe as the project of
explicating the scrupulous mathematical
unification attempts
first and foremost and secondarily
understanding what consciousness is and
what its constitutive role is to
fundamental reality and thirdly
investigating some of the
mysteries of the universe such as times
arrow
origins of life by the way we're going
to be doing that with brian keating and
lee cronin soon the placebo effect etc
hopefully this helps contextualize to
abbreviate the toe project is more akin
to dropping into a professor's office
hours than it is a podcast per se and in
fact maybe the podcast format will be
dropped in a year or two i don't know
but either way that leads me naturally
to the next point toward the end of the
year we'll be exploring more eastern
philosophies since as i've been studying
forto both objectively that is the
rational standard academic approach and
subjectively that is experientially
trying to live what's been preached a
meditative a contemplative approach i'm
beginning to see the utility and
simultaneously this enveloping quality
of language finding myself being drawn
to that wittgensteinian forsaken ladder
where the whole point of talking is to
realize that there's no point in talking
to this end i'll be exploring
philosophies precipitated by the vedic
traditions and at least attempting
different meditative styles now i call
this merging of the western form of
knowledge and the eastern
abbey gnosis you can think of it as an
extension of the scientific enterprise
albeit with an altered epistemology the
latter half of the year is also
dedicated to exploring some of the
viewers theories of everything such as
tyler goldstein's theory of everyone and
steve agnew's matter action theory each
of whom is active in the discord by the
way and the link to both the discord and
their work is in the description there
are two more substantial announcements
but first you should know that if you'd
like to contribute to the toe channel
then do consider going to patreon.com
kurt jaimungle as the patrons and the
sponsors like brilliant and even amjad
hussein of course
are the only reasons i'm able to do this
full time currently it's just me kurt
executing on everything from guest
selection to guest booking to
researching the papers which is
endlessly
fascinating but also time consuming to
time stamping to editing the episodes
and every dollar genuinely helps much
more than you may think now on to the
announcements i'm working on a toe
manual what i call a tome and i imagine
that by the end of the year it will be
at a preliminary draft stage it will be
a rigorous explication of the tolls that
i've encountered aimed at the graduate
student level or at the sufficiently
motivated undergraduate level it takes
quite some time to write even a quarter
of a page into this book so if you don't
hear about it for another year then
thank you for your patience the last
announcement is to placate those who are
more interested in veltan shaoongs that
is a framework through which to
interpret the world with an ontology
that's consistent with action during one
of the summer months of this year let's
say july i'll dedicate that month to the
more cognitive scientific theories of
everything such as that of daniel
schmottenberger greg henriques also has
a theory of unified knowledge jordan
hall and of course ian mcgilchrist i
hope this compendium was useful to you
and that you now have a clearer
understanding of the trajectory thank
you so much i'm glad you seem to be
enjoying the podcast and finding some
utility in it here's to 2022
you